the holidays are here and Shoppers are
spending Tiana Barber owns with love and
Company in downtown Summerlin selling
organic products because we make
everything here we get here very early
in the morning so we get here around six
and then
um we leave here around three o'clock
and we are just making Around the Clock
we're making the baskets
despite inflation and Rising costs
Barber says many people are coming out
to support small businesses and Shop
local we definitely definitely see the
difference and I know a lot of stores
around here see the difference that
people are a little bit more mindful
with their money and you know we have a
lot of customers that they're saying
this year we're going to give
um
you know a little bit more good energy
this past weekend we sold
um 300 pounds of our healing bomb and
400 pounds of our magnesium bomb
it's the same Trend across town this is
Skin Bar in Henderson where you can buy
makeup and skincare Services owner Linda
Moore says they've been booked with
appointments and are doing a lot of
online sales so she's going to keep
holiday promotions and Deals even after
Christmas we are busy with orders and
also I am constantly running to the post
office because we have so many people
out of state or that have moved out of
state and they still want their cleanser
or their moisturizer that they can't
find in Alabama Moore says this time of
year is key for many mom and pop shops
not only are you buying a unique gift
for your loved ones this Christmas but
every dollar you spent helps local
retailers Thrive I felt there was so
much competition with Black Friday with
online with Amazon I feel like we're
busier now you know last minute you know
getting the last minute gift so I feel
like we started out slow we started out
slow and now we are just really busy